My name is Riski Sububakia. I'm from
Bajarasin South Kalimantan. My question
is in Christianity they worship Jesus a
sapier. But in some Muslim circles there
are also those who worship human such as
religious scholar or the this is sign of
Allah. How does Islam view this? Thank
you.
>> If I heard the heard the question
correctly. Christians believe that Jesus
Christ peace be the savior in some
Muslims they also believe some human
being their savior
depending what type of savior if they
believe same savior like Allah then it
is wrong you can ask help from a normal
human being okay but you cannot ask for
ultimate help you cannot pray to anyone
but Allah
you can pray for a person but you cannot
pray to a person in Islam you can only
pray to Allah
and the ultimate help
you can only ask from Allah. little bit
help like oh okay shift the table shift
the microphone I can ask anyone but
talking about the ultimate help
worshiping only Allah and no one else
you can pray only to Allah you can pray
for someone else but pray only to Allah
hope that answers the question
>> thank you so much